yaris ne dit jamais assez mais je vous
le dis et si vrai que je devrais le dire
encore plus c'est grâce à vous bien
entendu vous tous qui nous regardaient
tous les soirs que tpm paix a pu exister
depuis huit ans et continue à cartonner
autant et l'émission vraiment est devenu
une grande famille c'est vrai et vous en
faites partie on avait honte on appelle
souvent les gens qui regardent tpm paie
pas les gens qui sont très assidus qui
me suivent également sur les réseaux
sociaux les fans jouent alors c'est pas
du tout péjoratif c'était une vanne qui
est partie au départ de camille combal à
vous rappeler de ça c'était c'était lors
du 1 truc sur ce que j'ai fait sur
virgin 17 avec mendy donnons exactement
avec beth ditto c'est vrai que j'avais
par les onglets comme incessibles j'ai
une licence et camille avait trouvé
cette appellation regardez qu'est ce que
c'est que les fans vous les fans jouent
c'est les gens qui vous regardent tous
fois mon poste on va qui nous suit voilà
et qui aime beaucoup d'émissions et
l'expression est né en 2012 cyril animée
elle aimait l'appeler l'époque
l'émission virgin radio france avec
comme invités beth ditto de gossip et
nora qui est avec lui lui pose une
question en anglais parfait et enora
ciridd bon animateur l'a traduit en
français et se dit je vais quand même là
reposez moi aussi en mieux qui n'aura
que non le voyage était de lits circus
c'est magnifique
est ce que c'est la première fois que
vous remettez le prix afad l'idiot deux
premières face time a fait 112
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça vient de là j'avais
même oublié ouais j'avais oublié on
embrasse tous les fans sont l'inde ayant
bien sûr c'est non c'est vrai que quand
je le revois ça mais le ghana pas
londres
ce que j'ai déjà eu ce oui alors c'est
mon gros problème non mais on rêve
problème de ma vie en revanche depuis
vous avez fait de peau des progrès en
anglais je trouve allégé recommandé mois
alors demandez moi un truc en anglais je
suis dit par exemple je suis extrêmement
contente passer cette soirée en votre
compagnie mes amis
[Rires]